that's how we roll
this can't be
the end of the world may have already
begun
there's an idea a symbol that must
continue to shield
there is no shield
the landmark 100th episode of Marvel's
agents of shield
mr. creel
figured I'd see you against here yes
well I told you I'd find you when shield
showed up again I told you I'm not
interested in being the government's
hired gun I'm done with that
didn't do Talbot any good yes well I'm
not interested in a higher gun
I'm putting together a team
general you always wear such nice suits
Touche
here you have an unusual problem
you should talk you should listen
if I told you we were putting a team
together
who's we
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie we just saw
the birth of agents of shields
Thunderbolts as well as their hunters
episode lead up so if you guys don't
know what's going on agents of shield is
having its hundredth episode next week
they're bringing back pretty much every
big thing that the show has ever done so
we're talking about Ghost Rider lash
life model decoys the Kree hive in Hydra
if you're finding me for the first time
there's so much Marvel stuff that's
coming we have Deadpool - the Deadpool
TV series not to mention all of the
infinity war stuff that's happening so
be sure to subscribe to get everything
so the biggest thing that they're gonna
do is reveal the deal that Coulson made
with the rider which i think is to
eventually become the next rider because
Gabriel Luna the actor that plays Ghost
Rider isn't gonna be available forever
and who knows what Marvel and Kevin
Feige is planned for the future of the
Ghost Rider character is like he could
show up pretty much anywhere because
he's a film level character but they've
only just started to get into magic with
Doctor Strange like it's still been a
relatively technologically based
universe so it's gonna be a little while
longer before we see a lot of magic
stuff happening in the movies like blade
or Ghost Rider I do think there will be
a blade reboot at some point nobody
the other big post-credits scene here is
agents of shield doing their version of
Thunderbolts which obviously is why I
included that Thunderbolt Ross clip at
the end I'm putting a team together
because Thunderbolt Ross created one of
the versions of Thunderbolts if you
haven't been watching agents of shield
you don't know what's going on you're
like where's Ghost Rider I'm just
watching for Ghost Rider she's putting
together their version of Thunderbolts
starting with absorbing man crusher
creel I don't think we've had him on the
show in a while but that's why he says I
don't wanna have anything to do with
that but she's like no no I'm putting a
team together the original version of
that team in the comics was right after
the onslaught period then like the late
90s and it was Baron Zemo trying to
reinforce of evil so it was kind of like
a separate thing most of what people
think of when they think of Thunderbolts
is like Civil War era Thunderbolts which
was basically them hunting down and
recruiting other villains in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so you had like a
couple really big Marvel villains that
were on the team from time to time there
was a version of the teams that had
Norman Osborn and venom on it that
eventually led to Dark Avengers the very
recent versions of the team had
Thunderbolt Ross as Red Hulk leading the
team right now as we speak it's actually
Winter Soldier leading a version of the
team so obviously a little bit different
from what's going on in the movies I do
think it's totally possible that they
could do a Thunderbolts TV show but they
might save that for Disney streaming
service or for a cable series I'm hoping
they don't try that on network TV just
so they don't have to water it down too
much like if you're gonna do
Thunderbolts do the hardcore version of
Thunderbolts but on agents of shield
they're basically building towards that
world cracking event like what was it
that destroy the world why do people
think that Daisy Johnson did it and it
has something to do with these three
model lists which is also the key to how
all these crazy things from earlier
periods on the show are coming back like
they killed hi have a long time ago how
has he come back so you have three
different monoliths that have something
to do with transporting things through
space-time so they're kind of using
these like their infinity gems these to
transport people across space and across
time in our reality I think this third
stone is like the mine stone or the
reality stone so it either magics up
things from your mind like they remember
hive or it transports things from across
the multiverse so there are other
realities where these things from
earlier
on the show her alive they haven't fully
explained the twist behind it but we
dealt with a lot of time travel early in
the series that's how they wound up 90
plus years in the future I think we're
also going to be dealing with the
multiverse they're really trying to go
out with a bang because the network
still hasn't said whether it's gonna
cancel or renew this show I think it's
possible that it gets another season so
I think because it's infinity war it's
the 10th anniversary of Marvel Studios
everybody in the Marvel Universe that's
doing either TV or movies is just trying
to do the biggest possible things they
can so this is shields version of that
and I've gotten a lot of questions too
talking about crossover between TV shows
and movies because the characters within
the show are on the FBI's most wanted
list meaning their faces their
identities are plastered all over the
world so then wouldn't Friday or
somebody working for Tony Stark and the
Avengers let them know hey wait a minute
Coulson is still alive
shield is operating again like we even
see Iron Man in shield gear during
Avengers 4 when they were filming so
it's like well clearly shield exists
somewhere in the movie universe so if he
ever wanted more evidence that the
movies and the TV shows are doing their
own two separate things never the twain
shall meet
this is it like I mean the TV shows are
trying to do their things with the
characters they acknowledge stuff that's
happening in the movies but I think for
the most part the movie people are kind
of like you know what we don't really
want to deal with any of that just have
your fun and the TV universe do what you
want to do just hear the rules for how
you're allowed to mention stuff so I
don't know that there's gonna be any
full-blown crossovers with movie stuff
this season because I think the network
the showrunners kind of sense that the
show is on its last legs
so they kind of want to cordon it off
but for the most part this show is
referencing stuff that they did in
earlier seasons kind of the same
situation in the Marvel Netflix universe
so Disney has their new streaming
service that's coming up you might see
more integration with movies stuff when
they debut that but they haven't said
what kind of TV shows they're gonna
premiere on that the next really
hardcore Marvel series is actually gonna
be that adult animation Deadpool series
that's supposed to drop in May I'm
assuming until I get more information
that it's gonna be after the Deadpool
movie but we'll see it'll be 10 episodes
so I'm actually really excited about
that but let me know in the comments
what do you think the deal Coulson
with the rider was do you think it was
just simply to become the next rider
because usually when people make
bargains with the rider it's for their
soul like I'll give you some power right
now but in the long term you have to
come pay the piper you will be the next
rider so this just sounds like that's
the direction they're taking things
because Coulson was poisoned when they
were in the future he's slowly dying
this is the only way to completely save
him is for him to become undead as the
rider
[Music]
the episodes gonna air next week so I'll
probably do a video for it make sure you
check it out remember shield is a Friday
night TV show believe all your bonus
video requests in the comments below I
am working on a black order infinity war
video because we got much better looks
at them congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Kevin Seeley please
private message me so I can get your
contact details there was a new round of
this video I'll just name a winner when
I post that black order video click here
to learn about the 10 phase for movies
that Marvel just announced and click
here for more infantry war promos thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome see you guys tonight
[Music]